over the past decade Tech salaries have
gone to the moon thanks to high profit
margins ubiquitous scale and seemingly
infinite growth potential there was
basically no limit when it came to
compensation it was almost like NFL
recruiting or something Engineers would
get offers from multiple top tier
companies and have them enter a bidding
war against each other and over time
this has resulted in entry-level
Engineers earning nearly $200,000 senior
managers Crossing $400,000 and directors
earning more than a million
per year and given that these
compensation packages often came with a
bunch of stock that was growing 5 to 10x
if not more we saw the rise of a whole
new demographic of multi-millionaires
and decamillionaires all of this peaked
in 2021 when demand for top tier
Engineers went through the roof thanks
to the pandemic Tech compensation was
growing faster than real estate prices
and at one point Zuckerberg was even
throwing a tantrum about how only half
of his top tier job offers were being
accepted but a lot has changed since
then and it seems that this decade of
seemingly infinite compensation growth
is finally coming to an end with high
interest rates and stagnating revenue
growth tech companies are finally having
to shift their focus to maximizing
profits this includes new monetization
efforts layoffs eliminating unprofitable
programs and of course cutting salaries
but this wasn't as straightforward as
you might think it's not like Google is
suddenly handing out compensation
packages that are a good amount lower
than usual this would not only make it
hard to recruit new Engineers but it
would also earn them a bunch of bad
press in the one area that they're still
highly respected strong compensation and
great corporate culture as such these
companies have decided to go about
salary Cuts in a much more nefarious
manner hiding them in the fine print and
seemingly pro-employee policies so
here's a behindth scenes look of the
overdo collapse of big Tech
salaries
to really understand how exactly these
companies are cutting compensation we
first have to understand how big Tech
compensation works for example if you're
a director at Facebook it's not like
you're earning $1.3 million per year
cash rather only 320,000 of that is paid
out in the form of base salary the vast
majority or nearly $900,000 is paid out
in the form of stock compensation there
are some exceptions to this rule like
Netflix who truly do pay out million
doll cash salaries but for the most part
a more modest cash salary plus an insane
stock package is how big tick
compensation usually breaks down and the
recent pay cuts primarily have to do
with the stock portion of the
compensation you see the stock portion
isn't exactly what it seems either it's
not like you're consistently pay the
stock rent every month just like a cash
salary rather the stock rant usually
comes in blocks of 4 years and then
locks in regular intervals throughout
that time period period for example if
an engineer was earning an average of
$100,000 per year in stock then their
actual compensation package was probably
$400,000 worth of stock over 4 years and
after the four years is up they might
get Refreshers or they might need to get
promoted in order to get another 4-year
Grant now all of that might seem like
too many details but it's important
because like I said the catch is in the
fine print the industry standard is for
stock grants to unlock in a consistent
manner throughout the vesting period as
at 25% per year anything else is sus and
there's usually more going on than what
meets the eye Amazon for example is
notorious for sporting an extremely
skewed vesting schedule in year 1 only
5% of the stock Grant unlocks and in
year two only 15% unlocks it's not till
year 3 and four that you receive 80% of
your stock Grant why do they do this you
ask well Amazon knows that the average
employee doesn't even last 2 years
meaning that they likely won't even
unlock their 15% for year two so when
hiring Amazon is able to pitch a
$400,000 stock Grant as an average of a
$100,000 per year in compensation but
the average employee only ends up
unlocking 5% of that or 20,000 saving
Amazon a bunch of money in terms of
stock compensation coming from Amazon
that's probably not all that surprising
but backloaded stock vesting is just one
trick in the book another trick that
companies use is annual vesting like is
the case with strip instead of receiving
a 4-year grant that unlocks over time
stripe likes to hand out a new one-year
Grant every year which makes it much
harder for employees stock comp to
compound with the company for example if
you are earning $100,000 per year in
stock and your company triples over the
next 4 years then you'd usually be
earning $300,000 in the fourth year at
stripe however you'd still be earning
$100,000 despite potentially playing a
crucial role in helping the company
triple these sort of vesting Shenanigans
have always been been common throughout
the tech industry but recently we saw
Google stoop to this tier as well with
their own
trick in 2021 Google adopted a new
front-loaded investing schedule which
consisted of 33% in the first 2 years
22% in the third year and 12% in the
fourth year at first glance it seems
like this vesting schedule is actually
more generous they're giving employees
more of the stock Grant up front but
don't be fooled that's by Design you see
if the overall stock rant stayed
consistent this would indeed be a
superior vesting plan but that's not
quite what Google is doing rather
they're using frontload of vesting to
inflate their firste compensation
numbers for example if you a potential
L6 hire at Google they might tell you
this we'll pay you industry standard
firste comp of 250 cash 250 stock and 50
bonus now that sounds about right but
the catch is in the total stock Grant
before the 250 stock that you would earn
in your first year was only a quar of
the total stock you would receive AKA
you would earn a total of a million doar
in stock over the next 4 years but now
the 250 stock that you earn in your
first year is a third of your total
stock comp AKA you now only earn 750 in
stock over the next 4 years and Google
saves a full quarter million and that
was just with their original frontload
investing plan since then Google has
become even more aggressive with their
front-loaded vesting their current main
vesting plan is 38% in the first year
32% in the second year 20% in the third
year and 10% in the fourth year again if
you are an L6 engineer this means that
instead of earning $1 million over 4
years you would now only earn
$657,000 and it doesn't stop right there
either Google has an even more
aggressive front-loaded plan as well in
this vesting schedule you get 50% in the
first year 28% in the second year 12% in
the third year and 10% in the fourth
year AKA instead of earning a million in
stock you're now down to half a million
and Google has effectively saved on
nearly a full year of compensation that
they would have previously paid out
obviously quite a bit of savings but all
of that only tells half the story one of
the main benefits of stock compensation
is that it can enjoy outsize returns as
the company grows but as big Tech
approaches maturity the expected Returns
on stock comp also becomes a lot lower
due to diminishing returns for obvious
reasons it's much easier to go from
being a $250 billion company to a
trillion dollar company than it is to go
from 1 trillion to 4 trillion and this
plays a huge role in total comp if you
joined Google in 2017 for example you
saw Google stock over triple this meant
that the $1 million stock rent that you
got when you joined was actually worth 3
million by the time that it fully
unlocked if you joined Google go in 2021
however you were actually down as much
as 45% on your stock but let's even
assume that Google ends up fully
recovering anded growing by 50% over the
next 2 years this would be phenomenal
for a mature company like Google but the
same cannot be said about your comp your
now half as large stock Grant of
$500,000 will only end up being $ 750 at
the end of 4 years in other words it's 3
to four times less lucrative to join
Google today than it was just a couple
of years years ago and all of that is
assuming that you're able to get the
same firste comp it turns out that that
itself would probably be quite
challenging everything that we've talked
about so far are Shadow Cuts things that
aren't really apparent unless you look
at the fine print but the truth is that
big Tech has had upfront salary Cuts as
well thanks to remote work big Tech has
not only had an opportunity to pay less
for office space but pay employees less
as well in fact Google directly cut
salaries of remote workers by as much as
25% now this isn't as bad as it sounds
because these Cuts were in line with
employees moving to lower cost of living
cities but this is nonetheless massive
salary savings for Google big Tech in
general has started focusing their
hiring efforts on lower cost of living
areas within the US and offshoring many
more jobs and sectors Google has also
caught a bunch of employee benefits and
even gone as far as tracking employ
badges to maximize productivity I've
been picking on Google for most of this
video but that's just because they're
the most notable example these same
practices have become common place
across all of Tech and if you were to
confront these companies about any of
this they'd probably have a couple of
key counterpoints they might say that
the overall stock Grant doesn't decrease
by as much as the investing schedule
might suggest for example 50% investing
in the first year would suggest a stock
comp cut of as much as 50% but but the
real number might actually only be 20 or
30% they would probably also bring up a
point about how they hand out stock
Refreshers in year 3 and four that could
help make up for any decreases in total
comp but regardless of how exactly they
justify it it doesn't really change the
fact that working in big Tech isn't
nearly as lucrative as it once used to
be back then your total stock comp
wouldn't have been 20 to 30% less you
would have still gotten the same
Refreshers in year three and four you
wouldn't be facing salary Cuts due to
remote work and the stock would have had
substantially more upside potential when
you put all of these factors together
you'll see that joining Fang today could
easily be 50 to 70% less lucrative than
it was in the 2010s not even accounting
for inflation with that being said
though it's not like Tech workers are
doing bad per se instead of a staff
engineer earning $4 million over 4 years
they might now earn 1.5 to 2 million
which is indeed substantially less but
that's still an insane amount of
compensation that's a lot higher than
you could earn anywhere else so I'm not
exactly suggesting that you feel bad for
Fang Engineers but it does bring up the
question of where exactly does this
leave big Tech well all of these
cost-saving measures are only now going
into place so expect it to take four to
5 years for all of the results to come
in but it's likely that the operating
profit per employee at these companies
will go up substantially this will also
be in line with these companies honing
in on their final push for monetization
so bottom line should go up quite nicely
across the board but that should be
pretty much it as that would result in
these companies fully maturing they've
spent the last 20 years on pure growth
which is now very much starting to slow
down so the logical move is to focus on
maximum profitability and reach their
final form and become the next CIS score
or IBM or Intel in the meantime we'll
likely see the best employees at all of
these companies leave and droves not
even because of the lower comp but
because of the work itself moving
forward their jobs will be more about
increasing efficiencies and reducing
overhead as opposed to building the next
big thing so it's only natural that the
aspirational types move on to smaller
companies where they can not only earn a
lot more but do a lot more and that is
the state of big Tech compensation today
all of this is rather new for Fang but
it's already been playing out in Europe
for quite some time check out this video
to learn more but until then I'm Hari
and I'll see you guys on the next one